Shindong author of almost a revolution
in the epilogue of your book you write I
believe the end of tyranny is near how
near well I think for me for a lot of
people to think at the movement in China
is over but my by my definition when
we're talking about the poor democracy
movement in China and see more
fundamental I've seen a more fundamental
way I mean the foundation for the last
Spring movement the people's
dissatisfaction the decentralizing
political and economic are trained by
the local government central government
reformers
versus conservatives and also you know
the faction it's been the army radical
intellectuals searching for the new
possibility for China
all these factors they were foundation
for the last Spring movement and they
were only deepened and strengthened by
the massacre itself so I think the
potential is still there and even
stronger and after last spring movement
we have our underground movement as well
as axial movement so I think the moment
still keep going
although they have a surface setback and
they paid a big price last spring
there's the cover of your book
who is this the the two students tan no
actress who were standing on a bus
trying during a demonstration you know
one of them was my friend what's his
name I don't want to give his name but
he's in Shanghai University one of the
Beijing biggest university so he's still
in China yeah
when did you leave China last June like
a week after the massacre and where are
you now I mean Brandis University in
Boston area
studying what studying biology and
philosophy and also my group democracy
of a telephone also back
democracy of a telephone also based in
Boston group my xio pro-democracy
movement organization it's called
democracy China in based in Boston and
what are you gonna do when you graduate
and you are a senior I'm a senior yeah
I'm applying in graduate schools started
to remove my academic interest to Patito
since and international relations wait
can you go back to China right now I
don't think so no so do you plan to stay
in the United States yeah I'm considered
the consider myself as exile that's me
you know I can't go back right now but I
will go back whenever it's possible why
did you decide to write a book well it's
it's very complicated when I came out
when I escaped from China I was
traveling around all over the world with
how the people was going out there you
know and that's the time I find out it
seems there are two Tiananmen Square one
is the one I really experienced you know
there are excitement frustration in
Fighting's but never leave the heart of
a social revolution another is a one
know kind of created by the Western
media it so each piece of the second
Kenema square so accurate but as a whole
it's quite a dramatic and and isolated
kind of stick out from Chinese history
people remember people know kenmin
square god of democracy is student in
front of Tanks but they don't know
exactly where the movement came from so
they don't really know where it goes so
it seems for them you know China didn't
make it they were closed and Eastern
European made it so that's the time I
feel the urgency to write a book as an
insider not only of the 19th a moment
but I said I said I young people young
person grew up in China for this such a
distinguished decade the so called open
door policy era since the end of 1970s
how my generation grew up and how this
new generation which is totally basic
totally new ideology shape the new
atmosphere in
Society in the finally shape and the
triggered the 1989 movement during the
the book we get to know your mother and
father and sister and grandmother mm-hmm
your father died recently where when did
he die and what was it uh he passed away
a month after I escaped from China and
he was he had faith or disease the blood
sensor but leukemia yeah okay Mia and
the part of the reason he died so fast
he did the disease was fun like n of May
and he died like two months later he was
too depressed in a lot of ways come and
put pressure on him and he was a
communist party member all his life he
was trying to follow so-called party
lines you know it his new he's his whole
life ideology and the Gandhi the
government asked him to be the spy of
his own son which also he trusts a lot
so it's this whole controversy in his
life you know for a long time especially
during the night 1989 movement he was
very depressed your mother how is she
she's soaked as she is still in Beijing
and working in a very big factories a
hospital and she's a medical doctor
she's a medical doctor yeah your sister
my sister as my father same as my father
and me she graduated from peak
University which we're very proud of it
of my family and she was working in a
government consulting company but after
my escape government for pressures on
her and took away her passport and her
working it gave her a lot of hard time
and now she changed to a foreign company
worked for foreign company in Beijing
and your grandmother my grandmother yes
she's she's fine she's 76 years old and
she brought me up and
she's still held healthy but the only
things she really hope can see me in the
near future and and hope I hope I can go
back soon to see her now this is a
picture of Emily yeah when I was very
young like that's the picture when I was
a hundred days you know after I was born
you say early in the book that your
grandmother at age three started to
teach you important things what kind of
things that you teaching yeah like like
a Chinese traditional literature though
all the important works like the three
current three Surry Kingdom and the
dreams about it is several important
traditional literature world okay one of
the things you keep reading our
references to world figures and some
American figures you seem to know about
one of them was Rosa Parks mm-hmm how
did you know about Rosa Parks when you
were growing up
not exactly Rosa Parks excuse me
it's we know more about Abraham Lincoln
George Washington and dr. King and
Franklin you know and as well as the
important figures during the Second
World War
it's really due to the so called
open-door policy in China one since the
end of 1970s the dunk champion after the
fall of martyrdoms dynasty they say ten
champions government opened door of
China to the world and Western material
is a source of Western ideas and
influential thinkers and politicians Oh
kind of rushing in China and my
generation is a generation grew up in
this totally new atmosphere not only
Western world stuff but also Chinese
intellectuals started to search their
own view at a time that there there were
scar literature so-called new tide
poetry as well pop music which totally
create a new kind
culture and this a pop culture and we
grew up we started think and grow up
from the this new atmosphere the
combination of a new Chinese liberal
liberal Adams fare combined with Western
ideals and Western materialists and we
have gradually have this new ideology
you know I would say is individualist
totally different from the other
generations in China previously and I
believe individualism in a way in a
psychological and cultural way is a
foundation for pluralism eventually if
you were still in China could you still
read these books right now it's that the
control is very tight but there's no way
to just wipe it out I was a Western
Western stuff I suppose I mean the
Western ideals and others are new values
have rather combined with a negative
Chinese cultural development so there's
no way for the central government to
wipe it out so it's still possible
especially you're not in cities like
Beijing or Shanghai which come true it's
very tight if an auto Beijing is quite
it's quite free still where did you
learn your English in China and here
yeah every Chinese University student
learn like two years so-called common
English education that's it as a part of
the open-door policy which have a great
deal of influence on us and you know we
take a big advantage from that you live
near tenement square yeah yeah it's like
a mile west from Tiananmen Square this
street my family house on the side of
it's cold I turn no peace Avenue China
and Tiananmen Square is kind of in the
middle of the channel an avenue explain
the kind of living conditions you had
when you were growing up well as it was
really different from American life and
it's very it's very crowded it's in in
Beijing a lot of families three
generations live in one room you know
and the
churros it's very it's very as Lake of
materials for the people line up a long
line to buy basic supplies you know but
you know it's different it's very
compare the level of the living is much
poorer than an American life but most of
times people are happy because it's all
that this ten years open door policy
people really feel the sense of growing
their life is getting better and better
how many rooms were there in your home
it's two rooms there are small rooms and
we my family beautiful nother small room
when I grow up you know I have my kind
of half room my own space yeah did your
parents own that no no it's owned by the
government how do you get your lodging I
mean in other words how were they
assigned through the PRT yeah through
working on it party and you feel high
rank officials they've got a lot of
rooms and if you're just normal
clerks workers you know small
businessmen or low rank officials it got
very crowded in our family and what
stage in your life did you know that you
were going to be an activist it's quite
the idea or is it zet having the kind of
shaping period is everything's when I
was very young is from my family was a
very liberal family she brought me up in
a very liberal atmosphere and I started
to involve in the social activities it's
kind of anti-government activity
pro-democracy movement era things when I
was 17 years old in 1985 why are your
parents liberal well there are in fact
rows so in China and in almost every
country they're always kind of Peron
ears intellectuals in at least in
theoretical one spiritual aspect and
also they are very concerned they
concern the social useful a lot and
there they were very idealist idealistic
when they were young
another reason is they graduate from
Peking University which is a political
and academic leading place in China for
decades
ever since 1919 may 4th movement and so
that's the liberal atmosphere I have but
there is always controversy not only in
in particular my family but all my
Parenthood and even younger than their
generation but we call Cultural
Revolution generation like 10 years
older than my generation you know this
fine balance to keep concerned and
unconcerned of the social easily keep
concerned mentally intellectually but
keep away from the dirac involvement
because it suffered too much there their
generation sacrificed too much and
didn't get anything out of it but both
your parents were members of the
Communist Party one thing my father was
not my mother because my mother so kind
of has this bad family background
because one of her brothers is in Taiwan
so there's no way for her to join the
it's a party although she really for her
whole life almost the coming hit to the
Commons part his so-called Commons part
is lying have your as your mother or any
of your sister been hurt at all because
you're over here and in the and the
Communists obviously know that you're
involved they'll read your book you
worried about that at all well like when
I said after I left China you know to
give my family a hard time you know
fortunately actually I will say
fortunately my father passed away he is
still alive since he is working he was
working in government here Oh God had a
very hard time and my sister had to
change her her job from a comma a
Chinese company into a foreign company
in Beijing and they took away her
passport she couldn't travel abroad she
was at one time gonna go study in Japan
yeah yeah changed her mind
or they changed it for that's it yeah
she changed for her they took away still
she's working in a Japanese company and
she couldn't go to Japan even the
company
so to go to Japan because she won't give
her passport the Chinese farmer two of
your grandparents committed suicide
mm-hmm why it's this is not only part of
the suppression the disaster the
communist party created before for for
40 years now but also involved in the
Chinese old tradition to the matter of
faith
lose faith the grace you know they were
viewed you know totally wrongly as a
so-called rich peasants although they
were very poor my grandpa was my
grandparents were in the countryside
near Shanghai since they have argument
with the neo communist party leader in
the village because they think they're
not they're corrupting they were
corrupting and their view that's rich
peasant and during Cultural Revolution
the Red Guard want to draw them to go on
some kind of demonstration you know
criticize and show them to the villagers
there as their friends so read before
the night they're about to go on the
street she committed suicide how many of
people like yourself who were involved
in the Tiananmen Square activities are
here in the United States now they're
students about you know more than 10 not
some 20 around but also there are
intellectuals much older than older as
60 or 70 years old also exiled from
China in our exile community it's a very
big as a student in this country there
are 75 thousand Chinese students from
mainland China in United States and
people who are very active and very
visible take very visible roles in the
axial movement is about a hundred there
are hundreds of them seventy-five
thousand mainland Chinese students in
this country yeah how many of them have
come since Tiananmen Square
eyes are about seven thousand but not
all of them most of them were not
activists in the movement because most
actives are in jail now
China can someone who living in China
who wants to come out now and go to
school here we'll the government allow
them to leave almost impossible there
are so many registrations like you
should pay a lot of fee almost
impossible fee for for Chinese family
like ten thousand Chinese dollars and
and also you should have direct
relatives overseas which not all of
Chinese do so is they put a lot of
registrations makes it it's impossible
for student to go abroad the it says on
the cover this Shenton with Marianne yen
mm-hmm
did Marianne yen actually do the writing
on the book yeah we rewrote it together
and she did a lot of job and she was a
reporter for Washington Post for five
years right now she's in Columbia
University she's she's a Chinese
American one here she was born in Taiwan
and an immigrant to to United States
when did you start working on the book
is in January and past January man woody
what's the reason what's the purpose and
what do you hope will happen with the
selling of this book is it do you don't
make money with it well definitely there
you know our new partner money part but
that's what I said I was really you know
the time I really feel I can read this
so Cottle Berger fee as a 21 years old
student is I really want the whole world
not only just remember Tiananmen Square
is a dramatic scene but also understand
our desire for freedom on the faith of
Chinese future and you know where the
movement are you can get wrong you gotta
try to get this book back into China now
the English version of train I'm trying
to also do the Chinese version and
smuggle in China is it possible to
smuggle things back into China oh yeah
definitely that's part of our exile
movement we brought us back to China
which can reach 80% population every
morning and also we smuggle our
overseas Chinese language newspapers and
magazines express our as excel moment
views and news about Eastern Europe and
all the world event going out and
smuggle in China from from South from
what Gong Gong yeah Hong Kong and
Marquart Island now you say your
broadcast to 80% of the mainland China
yeah we cover 60% of the land but reach
80% population how we have we made the
tapes in Chicago our radio station June
1st project June 4th of June 4th in
Chicago and we made the tape there and
brought us from Taiwan and several other
places around China in you know in the
mainland China you hear back from people
after you do oh yeah
they read to us all the time wait we got
you know tens of mails every week what
do they say this I mean first of all
they're the is now it's a value about
the uncensored news is one part death
and it's valuable more importantly
people feel the strong hope from the
fact we're still have the voice in China
as exile movement and we're bringing
hopes to Chinese they really appreciate
this you know our our work and the
encourage us to keep up the work when
you were living in China and in high
school and in college and in the school
you went to was was a peak University
Peking University yeah by the way how
did you get in there well we we had
so-called
college entrance examination which is
very it's like the SAT in this country
but much harder because you know it's
very hard and you must pass that it's
almost the only standard for the student
to get in school especially very good
school leading university like peaking
university so people spent at least half
a year or a year somebody do it over and
over again for several times
to take the test and that do you have a
choice of where you go to school I mean
in other words you can you can have
choice but it's only depends on your
your your grade on that and so-called
big test can you then choose what you
want to study yeah yes yeah but when you
choose your major it's not like liberal
arts education in this country when
intrusive major in the very beginning
before you enter the university you
should stick to it basically you can't
study and I mean I was about your major
all my classes only biology can
chemistry and the philosophy you know
you can't easily switch to a philosophy
although I'm very interested in and now
here in Brandeis I can study both
philosophy and biology when when you
were in school what kind of things I
mean Americans like to think that they
spent millions and millions of dollars
to the voice of America and things like
that influencing people inside China to
stand up and and you know before
democracy did you didn't even get
through oh definitely the VOA BBC and
Hong Kong newspapers magazines have very
big impact on Chinese people is it
because people view all this new sources
as uncensored it's a real free press
meanwhile tea and you know generally the
things Chinese press and it is Chinese
press it's old garment controlled or
should go along with so-called party
lines but as a document sent by the
party although they're also in the in
the in the press internal amount of
journals also reforms for years already
and and still VOA and BBC and Hong Kong
Thailand magazines and newspapers still
bring real news and hopes along with our
broadcasting station and newspapers to
Chinese people and I I just hope they
can do and keep up the good work and
also making more freer news i I know
there are a lot of concerned about the
Chinese government
you know by the by the broken station I
hope they can really have a free
precision of this issue go back to what
would you say was the beginning of
tenements square but when when when did
the activities that you first got
involved in in European lead to what
eventually became the June 4th situation
I think they'd say a 1989 movement was
explosion of Lee after whole more than
10 years contemporary Chinese
pro-democracy struggle erasings in 1978
democracy war movement at the time I was
very young I was 10 years old anything
involved although that was it's a
democracy war movement it's just like
two minutes walk from my from my house
and that said how that's a milestone for
the contemporary Chinese struggle for
democracy and it really set up the pace
and you know gradually started to do
this kind of self education for the
whole nation for what democracy really
means what pluralism means was a problem
with the system and the almost every
year after that you know there was as
elite an urban area movement gradually
become bigger and bigger till 1989
finally it's become a real nation worth
involved all the cars it not only elite
the only intellectuals of students but
also workers journalists and peasants
even you know it's a whole nation
started in the 1989 I read in your book
that font and I'm a mispronounces Fung
leisure finally drew spoke to a class or
a some kind of an event at your school
and he was then a member of the
Communist Party
he was the Communist Party and he was
vice president of a university
another major university in middle china
is code university of science and
technology and he was a rest president
there and he his he became for years
the symbolic leaders
of radical intellectuals you know
welcome verging the Chinese Carmen
open the door more and more and welcome
more Western ideas Western format of
democracy so he becomes the hero and
single in a lot of a young students
Chinese student and he is is he still in
Cambridge yeah he yeah he escaped yeah
to Cambridge is he coming here he's
coming I believe to Princeton next year
have you talked to him since he's been
out yeah we contact him and he is his
sin in the school and doing his research
and meanwhile keep you informed of the
Exile movement and hero in his own way
involved in the humorous struggle for
China but again go back when you were in
school was he one of your heroes when he
came to speak to you did you follow him
after that oh definitely he has a big
impact and not only him their whole
school of you know and I would say
radical liberal intellectuals you know
gradually grew up in in this open-door
policy older intellectuals and he had
they all have a very big impact on our
generation on the students on Congress
how much were you involved in the actual
tenement square events as a leader and
what was your role you mean the 1989
years I was in charge of a group called
the Olympic Institute along with several
other groups like campus student group
like democracy so long hired by another
student leader London we started when
after a fire bans death started the
movement in in peak University and then
in Beijing you call an Olympic Institute
yeah that's a group I always had of
before the movement started and after
movement started I was in charge of the
new center we have radio station
newspaper as well as we're holding a
press conference for Western journalists
and and then
me and another student organized the
dialogue delegation one of the three
still in leading groups which our task
is to negotiate maintain the ties with
the government had negotiate holding
dialogues represent the student and till
the end another thing I remember is that
Winston Lord who was ambassador to China
from the United States spoke to one of
your classes not my class the group had
mentioned before democracy so long which
is a group work closely with my Olympic
Institute the open discussions every
Wednesday it's also called Wednesday
forum and Winston Lord as well as
furniture was there spoke to the student
and the government would allow them well
at that time it's it's always very
tricky in the country with miss
dictatorship like China you know one the
Admiral general has various kind of
loose you can do something as for as far
as you don't cross seem sir invisible
line you don't cross that line you can
do something quite free but if you crop
across that line you know which a
frightened the government their
crackdown like what happened in June in
1989 but the lead periods are a very
long lead period before the movement
emerged which we hold open discussion
and campers we contact and discuss with
social activists SOS radio in flag shows
for a long time and also we even
precisely plan and prepare for the 1989
movement although the outcome is it's
kind of Auto control there's a lot in
this book that we're not gonna be able
to talk about but one thing it's a
little bit off the subject here I read
this almost in the last page of the main
book I had never hugged anyone in my
family and I didn't do it then you write
a lot about the lack of physical
relationships between families no
hugging or hand-holding and things like
that where does that all come well
definitely too
custom in China the way Chinese related
to each other quite different compared
with Americans so we really kind of hold
back it's more inside a national as a
nationally as hall and but that's one
thing also I think is changing in my
generation rediscover the freedom of
individual we discovered even the sexual
in the sexual freedom in a number of
other ways here's a picture of you and a
girlfriend by the name of Andrea yeah
she's still your girlfriend yes she she
is a Brazilian she was my schoolmate in
China and now she's in Wellesley College
so she's right up there near Boston oh
yeah and this is a picture of the two of
you holding hands is that something that
how did you learn the personal affection
compared to all the other people in that
well it's a quite commonly in my
generation of this kind of big surprise
for my paranoid as one has said we
really discover not only in in a deep
philosophical way the individualism the
seeking the hope inside ourselves
questioning without culture questioning
the government well meanwhile you know
we we export you know a lot of new
things which kind of you know new very
very new for the older generation
include senior sexual freedom what do
you think of our government I'm very
disappointed and the axial movement
Chinese axial movement it's very
disappointing that George Bush
demonstrations on the on their policy of
seen of American relations
I think the Porsche ministration is
choosing the wrong side of history in
this issue by choosing the Beijing
regime versus the Iraq's our woman our
pro-democracy movement in another word
people's desire in China
and I think you know when I came to this
country people was told me after 1949
there was a phrase in this country said
we lost China simply referring to the
Commons part he drove away coming down
to Taiwan but I think if the Bush
administration keep doing what he's
doing on the sino-american relations
here one day he will say there will be
another face very loose China again what
do you say to those in China who might
say I'm glad that George Bush has kept
the lines of communications open because
if he didn't have a most favored nations
treaty and things like that the door
would be closed and we wouldn't have any
dialogue now I agree with that that's my
point of view also to your fine lines
the fine balance is first of all we
should keep the door open to China
because it's open door policy brought up
all this and the door must be open to
China
although the Hollanders invasion try to
shut it down completely but meanwhile by
remaining the relationship with China
trade relations diplomatic political
symbolic relations the American
government and other governments can do
more than cut down totally the
relationship so by granting the MFN
status you can you can do differently
than what your administration has done
by putting conditions you know the this
country I don't need to talk about all
the techniques that mr. Bush knows
better than me the your country has done
so much to other countries or other
issues like South Africa like Soviet
Union so many other examples but
remaining relations you can really
promote in long run the people's desire
for the democracy for China like you
know the condition can be released all
the Palio prisoners and there are
thousands of drama in jail if they are
released it's a big is a big factor it
will be a big factor and strong impact
on the current underground movement in
China you write a lot about seeing
friends of yours or people that you were
in the square with killed right in front
of your eyes mm-hmm yeah so during the
massacre night yes I was on the
a Chang'an Avenue the I eternal peace
Avenue a mile west from the square which
was the most brutal killing field of the
massacre night and a lot of people are
talking about how many people died in
the square actually it's kind of
misleading by the Chinese government
because there were not a lot of people
died right in the square the people who
all said Square especially the west part
of city were trying to prevent the
soldiers martial law soldiers from
rushing in the square and crackdown on
the on the student in the square and
it's there a lot of people were killed
and got down by the martial of soldiers
what's this picture on top right here
that was a the negotiation is a garment
one me and another cop resident of a
dialogue delegation went to the
government liaison officer and after a
close to a meeting all the journalists
were surrounded us and asked what
happened what's the what's his picture
right here that was May 4th
demonstration that was anniversary of a
very important movement in 1919 may 4th
movement its 70th anniversary of it when
me and Wanda and the Australian leader
lead the peak universities demonstration
go in the square when when you think
back of the friends you made and all
that this is the giant and then you get
a picture here where is the giant and
who is he he he is chinese-american he
was my schoolmate and a roommate when I
was in pick University and recently he
graduated from we can't pick University
and now in Los Angeles so he came back
to the stage yeah about this fellow
right here he was my high school
classmate and he was in Shanghai still
in university studying was he involved
at all and they have Tiananmen Square
activities no but he was in Shanghai a
city in the middle
China where was this picture taken it's
amazing when I I described when I
prepare the big test the in college
entrance examination written on the back
wall is smile yeah yeah if you was very
tense period for every student it's like
it's like it's like horror for everybody
so I just try to let me you know relax
and what's this picture down here it's
it's a happy period it's after me and my
best friend Darwin enters the our
University and we took a picture in
Beijing what if you had the government
that you would want what would it look
like well the the final format of the
democratic political structures there
are a lot of format which we can we can
do search I mean for China exactly what
China should look like but I think it's
more important now as democracies as a
pro-democracy movement in China there's
a stage where our now I think it's more
important to figure out what kind of
ways we're taking in order to get that
final democracy I think China should
undergo the several approaches is a it's
a combination of Hungary Poland and
Czechoslovakia revolution for years
which I mean the internal war reform and
the opposition political force as well
as general people's awareness for what
democracy really means people's
recognition people of human rights and
people's political awareness you during
the tenement Square activities you spent
a lot of time with reporters mm-hm
I remember that you you had a dialogue
almost daily with a couple of Hong Kong
reporters SOS Canadian French and
American reporter yeah they're from very
beginning I was in charge of the new
center for the whole movement in in
Peking University so we hold press
conference as well as you know the yeah
broadcasting station the radio station
is right in my dorm room and also the
newspapers where
newspaper headquarter the only
independent newspaper run by students do
in the movement and you had a broadcast
station that you broadcast to Tiananmen
Square is it's a it's based in Peking
University so you can basically reach
the so called university town in the one
area in Beijing which a lot of
universities out there what impact if
any did American television have on your
movement
did you see American television programs
at all no not really we can't really see
it but for my case I was the first news
about the crackdown it's pre crackdown
ended an afternoon of June 3rd and was
it through CNN in in very fancy a
joint-venture hotel in Beijing and I
don't think a lot of people really watch
was the Western media report on the
movement during the movement but they
definitely know there are a lot of
reporters so they know the movement a
struggle they are holding our I
witnessed I watched by the whole world
that's the one that's a one very
important difference the night hand
movement has compared its previous
movement and reading your book use you
see that you're always having
disagreements among the students as to
when to pull back and when to insist on
dialogue mm-hm
you think that if you'd have pulled out
of the square before the third and
fourth that you would have could have
avoided the deaths and still made your
point if we hold this a theoretical
discussion I think we we would I mean
you feel laughter Square earlier
probably we can avoid the Moscow itself
but I think a country like China was
such a strong suppression whenever they
got in mass movement like the last
spring
there's no way to a so-called control
either by government or by so-called
leaders of the movement because it's
just like a broken dike so if if
somebody asked me you know what can I do
differently if I can do it all over
again I think the only thing I can do
differently is a timing there's a one to
trigger the mass move
so like what I mentioned before I think
China should undergo the three
approaches for enough time and then we
should trigger the next mass movement
like last spring and the difference will
be they can make it inside of a big a
big prize doing the masker Knight whose
get all the power in China right now
right now the central garment is very
powerful you know in Beijing the they
are trying to control everything you
know like what they did for four years
after 1949 but meanwhile they are
decentralizing political and economical
train is very strong local government
especially the coastal area the getting
greater greater of power you know in
kind of seeming independently and
meanwhile the faction is in the army is
also very strong and the base of how
people dissatisfaction the central
government power is striking and all
more importantly after the first fire in
Tiananmen Square in Beijing they totally
lost their legitimacy among the Chinese
people is there anybody that is dunk
shot paying still in power leepung are
these people these people matter anymore
are they short they are very important
now in the China's politics and as they
holding the power tightly by holding the
army at least trying to hold an army and
the whole country and the whole press
you know as much as possible and it's
very it's it's very crucial the
hardliners like Deng Xiaoping or others
their death is very crucial for our
progress for our struggle pro-democracy
struggle but on the other hand a lot of
people think only after their they dad
we can keep going our movement which is
not true because they didn't see they
see one hand this very strong factor I
agree with it but meanwhile there are
other factors so local gamma factor that
say free economies situation in China
factions mehar me all the things
meanwhile added to it on the ground
movement as well as very strong exile
movement all these factors plays an
important role in the
China's right now the the current
political picture and I think in a way a
lot of people's thinking about if you
deal with China's only ways deal with
Chinese the Beijing government is
correct if China was 20 years ago but
it's not correct now after this more
than 10 years open to a policy in 1997
Hong Kong reverts to the under the
control of Chinese there's 6 million
people sitting right on that southern
border there mm-hm
with a lot of private enterprise and a
lot of successful business and business
activity and what right across the
border in Guangdong there's a lot of
activity also is that southern attitude
gonna move up through the country oh
definitely I think it's an Istanbul a
lot of Hong Kong people worried of 1997
but I in a cracking very when I see the
China's picture as a whole all the
problem really the China I think it's
the amazing garment should be frightened
by you know taking back the Hong Kong
because there is a real free society
you'll have a great impact as what it
has already provided for China for years
especially South China and intellectuals
in a coastal area and it's not only hong
kong the problem you know the issues of
taiwan free tibet movement and others at
macau mongolia all the things all these
issues related to the mainland china
politics
we all have their own role important
role in the future China's political
struggle do you hope to go back someday
and live in China definitely yeah as
soon as possible
do you don't like it here no I like it a
great deal and I I really learned not
only from the school in the academic
world but also learn agus as a political
activist a great deal from this country
what really democracy means what
democracy looks like as I will say
institutionalize the democracy society
you know democracy now only the ideal
the people's desire for society gonna
guarantee basic human rights and it's
not only in the garment structure of
Free Press
or the social balance but democracy
become a sense of citizenship of
people's individual involvement you know
in the society so I really I enjoy my
life here and I'm grateful to this great
nation here's what this book looks like
almost a revolution Shen Tong is our
guest and we're talking about his
activities in relationship with
Tiananmen Square it's actually a lot
about your life from the early days
Seiji ozawa the conductor of the Boston
Symphony Orchestra you know that Mary I
mean you've you've you've listened to
him play Beethoven and how did that
happen well that's part of the so-called
open-door policy when the it's it's the
end of 70s the oldest Western culture
you know started it was in China before
the Cultural Revolution and he's totally
shut down during the ten years disasters
since 1966 to 1976 and there are two
years kind of fleet period before the
real open door policy started in 1978
you know the Western music you know
classic as a pop music not only
Beethoven or Mozart Oh
Tchaikovsky but also beat hoes Simon
Garfunkel and even John Donne for what's
there and his everybody know their name
as well as Martin Luther King or Abraham
Lincoln's name who taught you about
Beethoven Mozart and Tchaikovsky well
they did generate all these things are
available were available at in China and
I was starting rolling with my evolving
teachers for a while and although I was
not allowing a good violin player my
neighbor forced me to stop and but
meanwhile it it taught me to appreciate
the classic music and it's become a very
important part of my life now was your
upbringing and your family even though
you say you loved and what a room and a
half or so is the family more than two
rooms and how would how would you
describe the conditions of how you lived
compared to what we have here well it's
really it's different it's not
now have a very tall building except
recent years to build a lot of fancy
hotel and tall building we was living in
in Jessa house it's a flat house without
just one floor connected with other
houses connected with other houses we
have so-called yard Chinese yard which
is several family live in the same yard
and they all each share several rooms
you know that it's a it's a traditional
Chinese yard you know we believe in that
and and a lot of yard are very good and
good quality house but not my house and
you know the original question was with
your grandmother and your mother and
father and the atmosphere they created
is it much different than it wasn't a
lot of other Chinese families whether
you said they're intellectuals would you
have would you have had a hard time
learning some of the things you did if
it wasn't for the fact that your parents
were intellectuals yeah correct
I if there is different you know that
the my family can Paris I mean it's a
basically a in fact row family your
mother and father in the middle here
yeah in the middle yeah it's my father
and mother and it's my sister on the
left yeah how did again how did they
become intellectuals my my mother was
original was nurse and she keeps
studying and become a family become
medical doctor and my father and my
sister they all graduate from Peking
University which is a leading University
academically and politically in China
what do you want to eventually do with
your life well now I consider myself as
a political activist for promote the
democracy for the future China and I'm
very committed to this to this cause and
I think I believe now I've spent most of
my life stick to this cause you think so
yeah and you said you you started study
biology when I was in China for a while
when it was like every tower type
student you know I really believe
science can save China and
and I enjoyed a lot by studying biology
and now philosophy but I will study
political science and international
relations for my graduate study
hopefully next year starting next year
and now I'm deeply involved in the axial
movement how do you afford to live I'm
on my own I'm live on a scholarship
provided by the Brandeis University and
then what happens after that if you're
going to be a political activist for
your family and friends back in China
how are you going to be able to pay the
bills once you get out of school now I'm
trying now I'm deeply involved in the
movement I'm trying to keep almost
impossible you know it's it's a the
campus life as far as I exact activist
life I'm traveling around all of the
world trying to bring people's awareness
bring up dialogues between the Chinese
community to the other regional to other
movement like like a civil rights
movement internal labor movement Eastern
European for democracy movement and
hopefully I hope I can get a scholarship
for my graduate study again and
meanwhile I'm by promoting the movement
you know we also raised money to keep up
our exile movement when you talk to
Americans that don't know China don't
understand it what do you tell them
about the difference in life and the
difference between the freedom that we
have versus what you don't have back
home well it's when I went to I went to
a lot of I give a lot of talks and
speeches to Americans mm what was going
on there at all I mean one example I use
which i think is very directed to them
you know because it's all this kind of
gathering that how I can tell them is
not possible in China and even if it's
possible you will always have quite a
few onion vited people among you listen
everything to say and taking mental
notes and you know for sure even before
you go there your name by present in
this in
in the gathering your name and even your
family names there will be on a
government list that's that's that's the
reality in China it's not imagination
this this kind of suppression isn't
control I mean Americans Allah has them
take the freedom they have here for
granted now the election just just
passed in a lot of the voters rate is
very low and they really don't know what
freedom means if you don't watch closely
you'll lose it again
and I and also in this regard I also
believe like dr. King said injustice
anywhere is a threat to justice
everywhere no you can't say you're
afraid when 1.5 billion people in China
are still struggling for basic human
rights and they're what they're
struggling for is something you enjoy it
so much here and even take it for
granted what was the hardest thing about
writing this book with Marianne Yin what
was hard about it it's not really hard
in term of our collaboration the very
hard part is the movement belong to
millions of people you know it's hard
for me to try to write in the kind of
historians view and also you know I'm
still it's an ongoing struggle I'm still
in the story I can't really have
so-called accurate oh not necessarily a
objective way to write it although I try
very hard to to write down to record all
the things happened minute by minute but
still you know it's very hard to to show
the so-called umbrella picture as a
historian but meanwhile you know by
writing the almost revolution it's
really strengthening my commitment to
the movement because I by reviewing in
such a systematic way my life and my
generations life is really encouraged me
to go to keep going on this road and I
felt you know the strong strength in my
inside myself because I felt a whole my
generation the young generation
I still with me keep my dream alive in
the back on page 339 you list a whole
bunch of people and where they are today
one of the people that was we only have
a couple minutes that was prominent in
the book was chai Ling where is she
she ran now when I wrote the book she
was in Paris and right now she's in
Princeton University so she's here now
yeah she's how come so many people went
to Paris well because the French
government provides the umbrella for
Chinese exiles and it was much easier
than the United States easier than
coming here because the Chinese
government would let you know no no one
day we all most of us escaped to Hong
Kong my case was different a flight out
of China and to Japan first and but the
rest of man is a scape for Thailand
macaw or many Hong Kong and they were
waiting there for other garment provide
refuge and it's a turned-out French
government Canadian and Australia
especially as French government at the
best so the Americans weren't as open as
they should have been in your opinion I
hope they can do better there are still
a lot of activists escaped to Hong Kong
didn't settle down yet although American
did sponsor some refugees here this is
what the book looks like it's called
almost a revolution and its author and
principal character in the book is shen
tong one of those actively involved in
the democracy movement in china thank
you for joining us thank you